Welcome, students, to
the chemotherapy of the
antiprotosal agents.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
We'll be talking
about the treatment of
these various
parasites listed below.
Learning objectives, as always,
and preparation materials,
links,
key points.
You can use this as
an overview of the
topic, you can use it
as a summary of the
however works for you.
These are all the drugs
we'll be talking about.
And this is the outline. I've
put this in here according
to the disease, the
infections that are covered.
So, we will begin with
agents for the treatment
of amobiasis, giardiasis,
trichomoniasis.
Two are starred here,
metronidazole, which
is the prototype
of this group, and peromamycin.
Tinidazole is just
as important, maybe
even more important,
because it's better
tolerated and less
frequent dosing.
But otherwise, it's
basically the same
pharmacology as we see
with metronidazole, so
I'm only asking you
to remember the one.
Peromamycin is an
aminoglycoside.
Here's a structure.
We'll be talking about this
structure in terms
of its activity.
This is metronidazole
structure.
It is in the class called
nitroimidazole. The
parasites here are
shown in the figures
at the top and in
the histology slides.
Of course, I'm not
testing you on this. This
is to give you the big
picture of what we're
talking about with these
infective organisms.
So metronidazole. Let's start
with the pharmacokinetics.
100% bioavailability.
It's usually given ******.
It can be given IV. It
can be given topically
and intravaginally, and
there are very low systemic
levels in those cases.
It's usually oral.
It gets where it needs
to go, all over the
body, penetrates the
body tissues and fluids
well, so it gets to
where the organisms are.
Hepatic metabolism, CYP2A6.
When you see 2A6, you
may think, gee whiz, I
never heard of that one.
What it's saying to you
is 2A6 doesn't really
metabolize that many drugs.
The CYP-mediated drug
interactions are quite
low for metronidazole.
Tinetazole, we see CYP3A4.
Unchanged drugs and metabolite
out through the urine.
Half-life in adults is
about 8 hours, so it's
given frequently throughout
the day, 3 times a day.
I've indicated here the
pharmacokinetic concept
that really is relevant
to patient care.
Hopefully that helps you
pick through all of the
information to determine
what it is you really
need to know. This is a
skill you'll need to have.
Mechanism.
Structure here.
I draw your attention
to this component.
This gets reduced and
it becomes a reactive
nitroso radical. That's
what that's called. It's
reactive. It causes
reactive oxygen species.
Oh, well, reactive
oxygen species. So it
works only in anaerobic
or microarophilic
organisms. If the
organism is an aerobe,
the drug won't work
because it needs this
reduction, this
oxidoreductase to convert it
to the active. Okay, so
what happens with these
free radicals, it causes
DNA damage. It causes
damage to other
macromolecules. It damages
the membrane. In any
case, the organism dies.
I put it in this little
circle here. Here,
reduction to highly
reactive nitrosa
radicals, then oxidation
of the nitrosa radicals
to get regeneration
of the reduced
metronidazole, and on
and on and on and on.
Resistance, fortunately,
is really uncommon,
but it would make sense
that if there's more oxygen,
then there's going
to be less activation
of the pre-drug, pro
-drug, I guess you
could call it, to
the reactive species.
Clinical applications.
anaerobic, and
pathogens that don't
use much oxygen, such
as entamoeba
histolytica, amoebiasis,
giardia lamblia,
which is giardiasis,
and trichomonas,
which is right here, T,
trichomonas vaginalis.
Please remember, because
this is something
you're going to see
more often than you
see for the treatment
of the amoebiosis,
metronidazole is
useful for bacterial
infections. Again,
anaerobic, obligate
anaerobic bacterial infections.
What else do you want
to see here? We need to
follow up with a luminal
agent because the
metronidazole now is going
to the tissues to eradicate
the infection that's
outside of the intestine.
Liver abscess is the most
common extra intestinal
infection caused by
anti-amoeba histolytica
side effects. Well,
it's not too bad.
It can cause some
headache and nausea and
dry mouth and a bad
taste in the mouth.
Some people may not
be able to tolerate
the tummy effects and
can develop vomiting.
Diarrhea can occur. Dark
urine is not worrisome.
CNS effects, patients
may feel a little dizzy.
This is rare, the
paresthesia is
rare, the tingling
and numbness.
And pregnancy, we
always want to know,
can we treat our
pregnant patient?
The drug does cross the
placenta, but it seems to
have a low risk to the
developing fetus. This is
based on observational
information over many decades.
The tinnitazole and
secnitazole, which are used for
vaginal genitourinary
infections, should be avoided.
The metronitazole and
tinnitazole have been
shown to be carcinogenic
in mice and rats.
And therefore,
it's the recommendation not to
use the drug
unless it's needed.
If something else can be
used, use something else.
Don't use it for indications
that it hasn't received.
And drug interactions,
well, metronidazole and
warfarin. Warfarin pops up
with practically every drug.
I don't have a
mechanism for you.
and tinnitazole as you
would expect, CYP3A4.
I do not have a
star on tinnitazole,
but you need to be aware of it.
Now,
there has been, and still
is really, the warning
about taking metronidazole
together with
alcohol, even if it's
in a cough medicine or
something, because of the
potential for this disulfiram
-like reaction, which
is the flushing and
rapid heartbeat that can
occur in that reaction.
There has been a re-evaluation
of the available data
suggesting that it is not
the case, but that said, you
should still caution patients
to avoid alcohol while
taking the metronidazole or
tinnidazole or secnidazole.
Peromamycin, now, this is
the luminal aminoglycoside,
that means it works
only in the intestine.
It is taken ****** because
it is not absorbed,
so it remains in
the intestine, hence
luminal, and it goes
out from the intestine.
It is a protein
synthesis inhibitor
because, as I mentioned before,
proromamycin is
an aminoglycoside.
I hope you can recognize my
handwriting. It's a
little loopy here.
It binds to the 16S
ribosomal RNA on the 30S
ribosome, just like other
amino glycosides, and
it therefore interferes
with protein synthesis
machinery leading to the
death of the parasite.
What do we use it for?
Amoebiasis for the disease
caused by histolytica, sorry,
entamoeba histolytica,
and following the
nitroimidazole therapy.
What does that mean? Of
course, that means the
metronidazole or the tinidazole.
But peromamycin has other
uses. The cryptosporidium,
which is a diarrhea that
occurs in HIV patients,
and Giardia lamblia, it's an
alternative, we give
metronidazole first.
I want to talk about the
sepatic encephalopathy a bit.
We mentioned it with
the aminoglycosides and
neomycin, so we'll mention
it again with peromamycin.
The drug stays in the gut
and it will kill some gut.
Killing the gut bugs
that will decrease
the organisms from
producing ammonia.
And if the ammonia levels
are decreased in the
gut they are therefore
decreased in the bloodstream
because ammonia passes
through it's by passive
diffusion into the
bloodstream so that is the
reason for using
peromamycin or neomycin for
managing systemic ammonia
levels in patients who
have a failed liver such
as liver cirrhosis because
the liver isn't working
to do that anymore.
Side effects, you expect
these tummy issues
and the parenteral,
the IV, which there is
one use for IV, which
I'll get to. It does
the same thing as
all aminoglycosides,
nephrotoxicity, ototoxicity,
and muscle weakness.
some questions to kind
of refresh what we just
talked about see perhaps
you would like to
pause the computer and
think about them maybe look
back think about it
first and then look back
what are the medical
justifications for using
two different drugs in
the treatment of amebiasis
and what are the drugs
that we put stars on.
So metronidazole is a tissue
-acting drug to eliminate
invasive trophozoites,
particularly in the cases
of amoebic liver abscess
or systemic infection.
Peromomycin is an oral
luminal agent that acts in
the intestines to
eliminate amoeba cysts and
trophozoites, and that in
turn will prevent recurrence
and transmission. of the
infection. The mechanisms,
metronidazole is activation
by the parasites nitro
reductase to nitroso free
radicals, which are reactive
oxygen species that damage
the DNA and macromolecules
and membrane and other
parasitic structures.
Peromamycin is a protein
synthesis inhibitor
and bind 16S ribosomal
RNA on the 30S ribosome.
And other organisms
that are susceptible,
metronidazole will
be active against
trichomonas vaginalis
and Giardia lamblia,
as well as the
Entomita histolytica.
And I mentioned before
and I'll mention again,
Again, metronidazole
is useful for
anaerobic bacterial
infections, and that
includes clostridioides
difficile.
When we talked about
the antibiotics, I
kept always saying,
except, except, except.
Well, this one is a
treatment for clostridioides
difficile that is
susceptible to it.
Peromomycin is active
against Luminol,
Giardia lamblia,
Cryptosporidium,
and we will get
to Leishmania a
little bit later.
For now we're going to
move to the treatment
of human African
trypanosomiasis, acronym
There are two forms,
the West African form,
which I have a slide
on, the next slide will
show this, and the
East African form. So
it's called trypanosoma
brucea gambienzi,
trypanosoma brucea rhodesienzi.
All of them are starred.
They're all very important
to understand for the
treatment of this disease.
Dexanidazole here
is in both columns.
Molarsiprol is something
called an arsenical.
So you see arsenic in here.
Here's arsenic on
the periodic chart.
Arsenic is toxic.
The approach to treatment
selection, that's
why these are all
important, is based on
the neurological signs
and symptoms of severe
disease. So, there is
non-severe disease.
There is severe disease.
Cerebral spinal fluid
examination is required
for patients with
signs and symptoms of
the late-stage severe
disease for patients who
cannot be treated with
fexamidazole. Okay.
Here's the trypanosoma.
We see them in this
blood smear, etc.
Causes sleeping sickness.
Gambiense West African
Sleeping Sickness,
those are the two
names, Gambiense HAT,
Trypanosoma Bruce
A. Gambiense, and
these are the regions
that it's found in.
still quite a number of
cases reported annually the
gabiansi form form is the
cause of the chronic form of
the disease the east
african sleeping sickness
rhodesiansi h-a-t caused by
trypanosoma bruceae rhodesiansi
causes acute rapidly
progressive and fatal disease
the regions that this one
occurs are the east and
southern Africa the other
part of the continent I've
indicated the countries here
Tanzania southern Uganda
Malawi Zambia and Zimbabwe,
and I indicated the previous
names of Zambia and Zimbabwe
because of Rhodesia,
hence Rhodesiancy.
Trypanosomiasis is caused
by the bite of a tsetse fly.
This is the big picture for the
treatment. It's
easier to think about,
well at least it's easier for
me to think about
it, If I know,
if I can see the big
picture of how they're
used, when they're
used, why they're used.
So we'll start with
Gambiense. This is the chronic
form of the disease,
the West African type.
For most patients, anybody
who's at least six years old,
number one is vexinidazole
and then we have these other
options this is for the
early stage non-severe disease
the hemolymphatic stage
in other words it hasn't
gotten into the brain yet
for the little children
Again, pentamidine
is the preferred for
the Gambiense HAT.
Let's compare now to
the hemolymphatic stage
of the Rhodesiensi. We
have Fexanidazole again
for anyone who's six
years old and older, but
not pentamidine for the
little ones, because
pentamidine is not as
effective as suramin.
Suramin is the choice
for the little ones.
If we can't get suramin,
we start with pentamidine
for the acute disease.
Remember, this is an acute,
rapidly progressive disease
that causes fatality.
When the sermon can
be obtained, then it
will be used instead
of the pentamidine.
Now let's look at
late stage disease,
the meningoencephalitic stage.
So this is, in other
words, the CNS stage.
Vexinidazole again for
non-severe disease.
but for severe disease it's
this one which has an acronym
this one because it works
better so here's the acronym
nifertimox efluorinathine
combination
therapy so those two
drugs are used together
for severe disease, late-stage
severe disease
for Gambiancy HAT.
Now, for Rhodesiancy HAT,
late-stage,
it's just melarsiprol. This
is the one that's the arsenic.
And we have arsenic
right here in the middle,
or at least half of
arsenic, a third of arsenic.
and this is late stage this
causes this is trypanosome
trypanosomes in the cns
there will trypanosomal
killing is going to cause a
large anti a large inflammatory
effect which is going to
lead to encephalopathy in
many patients, in a certain
percentage of patients.
So to manage that, to
reduce the severity
of that inflammatory
response, the melarsoprol
is given together
with prednisolone.
If melarsoprol can't be used,
texanidazole does cross
the blood-brain barrier.
It can be given, as they
say, for compassionate
use. The patient has
to have something.
But the melarsoprol
is the most effective
drug for rhodiziancy,
HAT, late stage disease.
It's also going to work for the
other ones, but it's so toxic.
And we have other drugs
that it's not used for that.
Okay, pregnancy.
Well, we don't have a lot
of data on these drugs.
The idea is to save
the life of the
mother and therefore
hopefully she can go
to full term and
bear a healthy baby.
Also, treating the mother
may reduce the likelihood
of transmission of the
parasite to the fetus.
Of course, we have
to look at the
newborn, examine
the newborn, see if
there are any
circulating topanosomes.
Okay, so what do we
give? First trimester,
pentamidine
vexinidazole. Second
trimester, then, we can
give the nifertimoxyfloranethane
combination.
second and should
be second and second
and third both second
and third trimester
i want to call your
attention to this piece here
pexinidazole should be
administered only if there is
a high confidence of long
-term follow-up up to two
years to for early detection
of relapse So why do we
have to do it with this
one and not the other ones?
Fexanetazole is
oral, and it does
cross the blood-brain barrier.
And patients go home
taking this drug.
So there may be issues
with adherence to the
drug therapy because
if doses are forgotten,
the organism can get
into and infect the CNS.
Therefore, and it
depends also on the
patient and the
severity of the disease,
therefore there can
be relapse, relapse,
and I'll mention
it again on another
slide to make sure
you understand. Let's
talk about the pharmacology
of the drugs now.
Oral, it has a huge
volume of distribution,
meaning it just
gets distributed
throughout the
tissues of the body.
Half-life, up to 27 hours,
so it's given once a day.
And you don't have to
remember dosing, but you
might find it interesting,
since you'll need to know
dosing as practitioners.
A loading dose is given,
large volume of
distribution, remember that
pharmacology concept,
and then a maintenance
dose. So the total
therapy is 10 days.
The mechanism, well, pretty
much like we saw with
metronidazole. The
nitroreductase by the parasite
will convert it to, will
reduce it to nitrosa-free
radicals, and that does
the damage to the DNA and
proteins and membranes and
macromolecules and whatnot.
Pentamidine, only
injectable, not
well absorbed
from the GI tract.
It distributes to
the organs. It's
high concentrations
in the organs.
Poor CNS ***********.
So we're not going to be
using it for the CNS form.
Again, 7 to 10 days of therapy.
Well, the mechanism
is not really clear.
So with all of these, the
suggested mechanism, the
proposed mechanism, is based
on what is actually known
about what the drug does
in laboratory experiments.
so pentamidine interferes
with the kinetoplast DNA
and the kinetoplast is
really the trepadosome's
mitochondria and that will
inhibit RNA and ribosome function
and nucleic acid synthesis
and the organism dies.
Leishmania is also a
trepadosomal type of parasite.
Now, Nifertamox, oral,
it's got a short half-life
though, so it's given three
times a day for 10 days.
And even though
this is an old drug,
there's not a lot of
pharmacokinetic data on
it, probably because
it is an old drug.
The mechanism, proposed
mechanism, is like
the fexanidazole, like
the metronidazole,
and e-flornithine.
Again, parenteral
only, IV only. It's
given for seven days.
Again, pharmacokinetic
data is limited.
But it is the suicide
inhibitor of ornithine
decarboxylase. That's
easy to remember
because it's got
ornithine in the name.
and that inhibits the
polyamine synthesis these are
molecules that are essential
for cell growth and
differentiation and various
functions within the trypanosome
adverse effects well
texanidazole is relatively
well tolerated especially
compared to all of the
others it can cause some
neuropsychiatric effects
all the way from agitation
and anxiety through
psychosis, hallucination.
It can cause a
decrease in the neutrophils.
So what do we do? We
just monitor. And it can
cause QTC prolongation.
Monitor ECG.
Look and see if the
patient is taking
other drugs that
prolong the QT interval
because that can
increase the risk.
Pentamidine, relatively
well tolerated again.
The major adverse
effects are electrolyte
abnormalities, hypoglycemia,
and renal insufficiency,
all of which can be
monitored and managed during
therapy. The patient
will have to be in an
area where they can receive
the parenteral drug.
administration.
Nifertimox, oral again,
common adverse effects
though, all these belly
things, nausea, vomiting,
anorexia, weight
loss because the patient
doesn't feel very
well, and it can cause
headache, dizziness,
insomnia, and And
polyneuropathy.
So, for a 10-day course
of therapy, probably not
as big an issue as the 60
-day course of therapy that
we see with American
trypanosomiasis treatment.
Eflornithine, oh, lots
of adverse effects.
The patient is really
probably not going to feel
well at all through this
therapy. Fever, itching,
elevated blood pressure,
nausea, vomiting, diarrhea,
abdominal pain,
headache, dizziness,
hearing loss,
seizures,
painful joints,
rash, hair loss,
bone marrow
suppression, so anemia,
leukopenia, and
thrombocytopenia.
The patient has to
be hospitalized where
they can get this
drug and be monitored.
Now, this is Rhodesiensi
hat, and I've
divided it this way
rather than horizontally.
So Suramin, this is something
called a polyanionic compound.
It does not cross into
the blood-brain barrier.
It's IV, slow IV
infusion, excreted in the
urine, detectable up
to three months. and it
has this really long
half-life mechanism.
It inhibits the
glycolytic enzymes
and disrupts energy metabolism.
It also blocks NADH
oxidation and that's going
to impair the respiration
and energy production
there. And it blocks pure
energetic signaling so
it's going to interfere
with cellular processes.
And it causes an immediate
hypersensitivity
reaction with shock.
Along with kidney damage,
peripheral neuropathy,
exfoliative dermatitis,
bone marrow toxicity.
Remember, this is the one
that's given to
the little kids.
less than 6 years old,
less than 20 kilograms
for the Rhodese NCHAT.
Now there's another
piece of this that
needs to be remembered
with suramin.
Onchocircovobulus,
right here, is a worm
and it is endemic
in certain parts of
Africa but usually not
in the areas where the
Rhodesian CHAT is
endemic. Nonetheless,
cerumin is really effective in
killing these ovulvulus worms.
And as a result, there can
be this immense inflammatory
reaction. So, the drug
sermon should be avoided
in patients who have
onchocircovovulus co-infection.
We'll be talking about the
worms in a later lecture.
Here's our arsenic,
arsenic, arsenical drug.
It's a slow IV infusion.
It's really irritating to
the vessels. penetrates
the CASF. Obviously, it
has to because we're using
it for the CNS Rhodesian
CHAT. It is converted
to the active trivalent
melarsin oxide. So the
melarsiprol is arsenic pentavalent
and the melarsin oxide
is arsenic trivalent.
Now, the malaricin oxide
just loves the sulfhydryl
groups, so it will bind to
it with strong affinity,
fortunately reversibly,
and it will form
this malaricin oxide
trypanothione complex,
which inhibits trypanothione
reductase, which inhibits
a number of the activities
of the trypanosome.
This I should have
probably put in
red, so I'll circle
it in red now.
Melarsoprol inactivates
many enzymes
in both the host
and the trypanosome.
Imagine, inactivating
enzymes in the host, it
can cause reactive
encephalopathy, which is
called melarsoprol reactive
encephalopathy, which
can be fatal. And this
is resulting from that
inflammatory response from
the dying trypanosomes
and the fact that
melarsoprol is arsenic.
Toxicity to all
organs can occur.
Avoid in pregnancy if possible.
Don't forget that
Rhodesian C. H.A.T. is
rapidly progressive and
fatal if left untreated.
All right. What are the
therapeutic uses
of fexanidazole?
Perhaps you'd like to pause the
computer and think about it.
All patients, at least 6 years
old, at least 20 kilograms,
for the treatment of
early-stage gambiancy and
rhodesiancy HAT and non-severe
late-stage gambiancy HAT.
What are the favorable
properties of
fexonidazole compared
with other anti-HAT drugs?
It's oral, safer
than other drugs, and
it crosses the
blood-brain barrier.
Why is long-term
follow-up after
fexanedazole
treatment essential?
Follow-up for up to 24 months
is required to detect relapse.
Treatment failures can occur.
Recurrence rates vary
based on whether or
not the patient is
able to stick to the
oral therapy, the
severity of the disease,
and the patient's
own immune response.
What are the preferred
agents for severe late-stage
gambiancy HAT and for late
-stage rhodesiancy HAT?
So gambiancy, the
nifertimoxifluorinothane combination
therapy, and for the
rhodesiancy, the melarsoprol.
and melarsoprol would be
effective in early and
late stage infection of both
forms of the disease. So
why is it only forest line
for late stage Rhodesian
CHAT? And the reason is
because it is so toxic.
And this is a chart really
that summarizes the major
actions and toxicities for
HAT treatment. It is also
at the end of this lecture
uncovered, of course,
so I'm not going to
go over it right now.
American trypanosomiasis
is known as Chagas disease.
It is caused by
trypanosoma cruzi.
There are two drugs that
are useful in its treatment,
benzinidazole and nifertamox.
And I've given you a
little information about
the disease here on
the front and the
structures of these two
drugs. So I'm sure you'll
recognize the
similarities here with
metronidazole. These form
nitrosoradicals again.
Benz nidazole is the
preferred agent only
because it tends to
be tolerable, more
tolerable than nifertamoxin.
It's only taken
twice a day instead
of three times a day.
The mechanism, as
I mentioned before,
is reduction by the nitro
reductase to the nitroso
free radicals generating
the reactive oxygen species
that form the covalent
attachments with a parasite
the DNA and other
macromolecules causing membrane
injury enzyme inactivation
DNA damage so this is
really the whole spectrum
that It can be applied to
the metronidazole and to
the vexanidazole as well.
Effectiveness, well, it
varies. Varies with geography,
the phase of the Chagas
disease, and the form of the
disease. So acute disease
cure rates are pretty good.
And the lower cure rates
with the chronic disease.
Okay, adverse effects.
Photosensitivity can
cause a rash, and that can
progress to severe dermatitis,
but not all that often.
That means covering up the
skin to prevent that effect.
Peripheral neuropathy, so the
pins and needles, and numbness.
Bone marrow suppression.
If it's severe,
then the therapy has
to be interrupted.
Nifertimox, GI,
and CNS effects.
Nausea, vomiting,
tummy troubles,
and CNS effects.
The irritability of
the disorientation,
headache, dizziness,
insomnia. and we see
again the paresthesias and
polyneuropathy and tremors
that are less common.
Importantly, the drug
should be avoided
in pregnancy because
animal reproduction
studies suggest
harm to the fetus.
Use in pregnant people
in Chagas disease
is limited and there
are no specific
recommendations for preventing
vertical transmission
of the disease in
pregnant patients.
Lushmaniasis now.
I have the periodic
table again on the right
-hand side. We're talking
about antimony now.
These are called antimonials.
Sodium stibogluconate, SB,
and megalamine antimoniate.
They do the same thing.
We'll talk about
Amphotericin B because we've
talked about it before
and also because it's
important in the treatment
of Leishmaniasis.
Miltephesine has an
important characteristic that
you should know about,
which is why I have it
starred. And Peromomycin
we talked about before, so
we're talking about it
again in another context.
Here is the antimony and the
structure of the
sodium stiboglucan.
Leishmaniasis is caused by
a bite from the sandfly.
Leishmania are trypanosomes.
They are endemic in
southern Europe, subtropical
and tropical regions.
They are obligate
intracellular parasites that
infect macrophages,
monocytes, and other types of
phagocytes. The diseases
are characterized by
inflammation, infiltration,
and necrosis. And I have
some pictures that I'll
be showing you. They can
cause visceral leishmaniasis,
which can be fatal.
They can cause mucosal
and skin infections.
They are given
parenterally, IV or IM. They
sequester in the tissues
and they are excreted
unchanged in the
urine and they have a
fairly decent half-life,
quite long in fact.
Mechanism, not
clear again so we'll
share what is known about them.
They are pentavalent
again and they
are converted to the trivalent.
They appear to bind to
sulfur thiol groups and
interfere with various
enzymatic systems. ATP,
GTP availability is reduced,
disrupts DNA transcription
replication, other
metabolic pathways.
Bottom line, it kills
the amastagotes in the
phagolysisomes of the
macrophyses. So it gets to where
the parasites are and
kills them cutaneous well
it can be given injected
right into the lesion
peromamycin can be used
topically and there
are some non-drug approaches
but that's not our
topic today mucosal
forms now the
antimonials are first
line throughout the world.
For the visceral type,
remember this can
be fatal if it's
not treated. Some of
you may have heard
of it as kala azar.
Amphoterrazin B is
first line, first line.
However, if it's not
available, then the
antimonial can be used.
Pretty good efficacy in
certain regions, that is to
say, in areas of the world
that are not india in india
it doesn't appear to be that
effective and in india it's
the amphotericin b that's
used especially in india
the pentavalent antimonials
are pretty well tolerated
uh however the toxicity
increases over the course of
the therapy with cumulative
doses. Remember how long,
the fairly long half-life
from a day to up to 80 hours?
But it is reversible after
the drug is withdrawn. That's
what reversible means.
Once the drug is withdrawn,
those toxicities will fade.
Cardiac, blood, liver,
pancreas, kidney,
muscle aches,
Tummy issues
Fatigue and rash
Monitor Prior to
and weekly during
therapy Monitor for
all of these issues
Pregnancy safety has not
been established Remembering
that visceral
leishmaniasis can be fatal
Patients should always be
treated without delay I've
put all of the drugs
for leishmaniasis
in this table, all
the other drugs.
Amphotericin B for cutaneous
and visceral, preferred
option including pregnancy,
and following treatment.
You don't have to
remember the doses.
They're here to
give you a sense
of how these drugs are used.
No reason to memorize
them at this point.
Miltefacine. So I said
there were features
about miltefacine
that you should
know, and this is the
reason it's starred.
Oral.
It's given ******.
The others are the
Amplotericin B is IV. The
antimonials are
parenteral, but this one is
oral, and it can be used
for all three forms.
Paromamycin is
used topically now
for the visceral leishmaniasis.
Paromamycin can be
used parenterally,
and now it will have
the same adverse
effects as any other
aminoglycoside.
Pentamidine also can be
used as an alternative.
You don't have to
remember these for now.
Toxoplasmosis, this is the last
infection that
we'll talk about.
Spiromycin and
pyrimethamine plus lucovorin
plus sulfadiazine, those
are the two options.
And I've included a
couple of other options
down here. You don't need
to memorize those. You
do need to memorize the
ones with the stars.
so toxoplasmosis cats are
the natural host this is a
worldwide infection that it
can i mean it's prevalent
worldwide most people can
are asymptomatic um maybe
a self-limiting illness it's
not treated but in pregnancy
and patients with aids it
is treated in pregnancy
the idea is to prevent
vertical transmission to the
fetus and therefore prevent
congenital toxoplasmosis.
In patients with AIDS,
they can develop
encephalitis from this
toxoplasmosis
infection. So that's
why those two
populations are treated.
In pregnancy, now
here's the spiromycin.
This is why I want
you to remember the
spiromycin. It happens to
be a macrolide antibiotic,
and it is used in
the first trimester.
Now, in the second
and third trimester,
then pyrimethamine, leucovorin,
and sulfadiazine can be used.
Leucovorin is folate,
active folate.
Pyramethamine, you
may recall, is a
dihydrofolate
reductase inhibitor.
Treatment of cerebral
toxoplasmosis,
pyramethamine,
leucovorin, sulfadiazine,
or IV trimethoprim
sulfamethoxazole.
So, here's a check of
your knowledge, a little
question. Which of the
following was frequently
used for the treatment
of leishmaniasis?
I invite you to take
a moment to pause
the computer and think
about the answers.
Also, what are the
drugs in each option?
So it is D.
The antimonials, toxic
trivalent antimonial,
interferes with various
enzymatic systems, which
disrupts ATP-GTP availability,
DNA transcription
and replication, other
metabolic pathways.
And the other drugs,
pyrimethamine, metronidazole,
fexanidazole, nifertamox,
benzinazole, and the
last one is peromamycin.
And looking at the
mechanisms of action of the
antiprotozole drugs, what
is the common thread?
That's a good question
to ask yourself for
all classes of drugs.
What is the common
thread? Why are these
all together in a class?
Antiparasitic drugs generate
free radicals, reactive
oxygen species during
activation, which damage cellular
and molecular structures,
or complex and inactivate
cellular proteins, or
interfere with metabolism.
Thus, the parasites die.
And I have a list here
of preferred drugs
for the treatment of
the various infections,
and I won't go
over them. They're
listed at the end
of this lecture. And
the summary is really the
answers to the questions.
And that concludes this lecture
on the antiprotozole drugs.